you need to write down what's with the
jeans you're a big believer no sex
before fighting yeah man I still believe
that man because I mean I do my thing
but you know that I don't you know you
know you know you know you got a whole
you know
no no say you know talk about I have a
vague idea what you're talking about
you know I'm saying
nah me know the hell we don't you ain't
say anything yet I don't know what
you're saying is that the job what you
mean that's a different guy right now I
don't know what you're saying I thought
what you mean you know I'm saying I love
you know I'm saying Supercuts it should
be out cuz you know Sam pictures getting
it at home no I'm saying you know
stomping down on them hoes and I'm like
well hold oh man I don't understand this
part of the game and it's it's bothered
me of my choice you know somebody minute
or you know sent he set me back him so
don't that my man let me tell you
something man you're not right you
caught the country Panther man you know
upset you know you pepin at a whole you
know upside 24/7 saying you know you
shuffling up the crowd you're not upset
you know you're trying to find out
exactly what's happening on that John
the track
okay cool what I'm gonna do I'm gonna
sit back and imma open up the track I'm
saying you know I told the whole jumps I
make you wait a figure-eight bitch
didn't want upset when I talked about
how you sitting in the first words out
of your mouth this you know I'm saying
no I mean no to hell we don't you ain't
say anything yet you know I'm saying but
I think this fighter is know I never had
a job before my life until I started
working for sue you know in and out of
jail
you own saying did a little bit every
time you don't say no no mm-hmm yeah I
don't you're saying that's the best one
cuz he literally says nothing on me
didn't get away you know I'm Santa a
mate oh no I'm a player at the end it
was a question we travel called I'm
saying it didn't go our way
they made a decent play you don't say I
had em see out a better look yeah I'm
saying so it was just something me don't
give me one more play than we did know
was another one like the game got out of
control and they came out a lot into
which we knew they was gonna do
so we fall bad we took the lead and I'm
Samba day though not sometimes and they
got the W did you had a terrific game
offensively what was the atmosphere out
there languid with the whole the whole
return of Iverson are you always gonna
be very emotional you know I'm saying
hey not going another player to come in
here and get more attention to loved and
they were getting I'm since are they
gonna come down a game buses and they
did and I'm saying but we fall bad when
you with the throughs in position to win
the game we weren't able to get it done
you know interesting playing against
Andre Miller and Reggie of us yeah you
know I'm saying they still only the
still close friends of ours you know
this is competitive but it's still love
at the same time thank you
it's so many do you know I'm Sam I'm Sam
you don't say yeah come on I'm saying is
any home sorry I'm so I'm saying I'm
saying no I'm saying I'm sensor and I'm
so bidding I'm Senate you know Sam
yeah I'm saying that's how many got a
2001 Chevrolet Suburban you know
for the city Shipibo six months to put
it together I had it like this like two
years now I'm say oh uh you know I can't
pop yo I'm saying ulong sang oh you know
I'm Sam that's all yeah a foreign person
yes with a quick listen to interviews or
hip-hop you aren't and how's that
thought what Mitch I'm saying it's mixed
up yeah yeah you don't say I'm usually
good motherfucker right there you don't
say so you know I'm saying he's like
I'll fuck with the real you know I'm
saying God right now I don't know what
you're saying I thought what you mean I
ah so good I like that Street the
fighter though that's my new favorite
you know what I'm saying the fighter
yeah because you know you know you know
you know you a big believer no section
for fighting yeah man I still believe
that man because I mean I do my thing
where you know I don't you know you know
you know you know you got a whole you
know Ono say you know talk about have a
big idea what you're talking about
and last week we had Ghostface had so
many Nami Nami your name it's no you
know me show me you know say yummy yummy
yummy you're on me you don't say you
know me you know me you don't mean y'all
say you know me you know me you know me
you know did you switch it you don't me
no buddy I said like a hundred